got off the top of your head what are
the biggest movies that have gone
straight to streaming coda
boom
Mitchell's versus the machines
that's probably all oh I mean
Chippendale Rescue Rangers I think is is
a good example of that too
um
but yeah I mean
there's a to me as someone who loves
movies
most movies that end up on streaming
don't have all the elements
that make them worthy of going to the
movie theater I mean
I think we would have seen coda in a
movie theater if it wasn't for the
pandemic
but I think a lot of these movies
again I I don't mean to crap on Netflix
when I say this is that Netflix to me is
the most guilty of all this
is that they have movies so many movies
that have right elements
but they never have the movie they never
have the movie that embodies everything
so Irishmen there's a great movie there
not at three hours
there's a great movie there somewhere at
two
it's like you have to have control of
that Meg there's a great movie there
don't know where it is it's lost
somewhere but they have them they just
need to kind of like have more
I know we want creative control for our
filmmakers
but you have to sometimes look at a cut
of a movie and kind of say this doesn't
work even a movie like the prom which is
is I would say is a streaming movie that
I actually
really wished went to movie theaters
that movie is even 20 minutes too long
and I think there's a struggle with a
lot of streaming platforms is this
creative freedom of being able to make
the movies that they want
but it doesn't really hold up
to a a movie goer because there's
there's elements to it that maybe we as
film critics or industry professionals
like the fact that oh yeah look at this
he really had the time to fill out the
scene and like it goes on and yeah like
that works but to an average person
you're gonna watch this again like why
is the same stuff going I'm so bored
like come on move this along
and I think that's something that's that
struggles a lot with streaming movies
the one thing that I will say
positively about Netflix with streaming
is that they really have
reinvented the romantic comedy
what they have done for that genre is is
great because they they
inspired a group of young filmmakers to
kind of start off telling these these
cute rom-com movies
and that's something that we lost in the
Hollywood System there's so few good
rom-coms and I've watched so many of
them on Netflix and and even like the
other streaming platforms like Hulu had
one um
called The Fire Island a couple weeks
ago and that
that was really good too
best rom-com
[Music]
best rom-com
I mean we have to go with a classic
right When Harry Met Sally
I mean Billy Crystal Meg Ryan can't beat
that and then I guess closely followed
up by Pretty Woman
so it's been it's been a couple decades
then since yeah I mean they don't really
have I love rom-coms but like
they're not there's not that many of
them that feel all that special
speaking of which one it actually does
come to mind is set it up which is
actually a Netflix movie
and that's what Zoe Deutsch and Glenn
Powell I think that's one of the the
most Charming ones that I I've seen in
recent memory
how would you compare your excitement
level for streaming movies versus
theatrical movies
there's
I know this contradicts something that I
said earlier about
you don't have to see every movie in a
theater
but there is something exciting about a
movie having a marketing campaign
so when you see a movie
and there's something to build towards
it
and seeing that on the big screen and
going to a movie theater and seeing a
poster or seeing a standing
it adds to it that gets really lost with
streaming movies
because
Bo Burnham jokes about this all the time
like there's
movies and TV shows and there's content
I feel like
a lot of what's on streaming is content
it's not really good enough to be
labeled as a movie or good enough to be
labeled as a TV show
but really like the kind of some stuff
that you would watch
just to pass the time
so while there have been some good stuff
both movies and TV shows on stream I
mean TV shows there's no question on
streaming platforms killing it I mean
movies on streaming platforms are not
there yet
TV shows are long past I mean some of
the best stuff that you can watch right
now aren't TV shows on streamers whether
it's Severance whether it's stranger
things
their squid game
they're there
movie wise theaters is still where it's
at and then every once in a while you'll
have the exception to a rule so to to
answer your question definitely
theatrical movies because of the
campaign there's a hype around it you
get excited you get oh my God a trailer
is dropping oh my God a poster dropped
oh my God casting news
you you get to see all of this and yes
you get the trades right about the
streaming movies and yes you get a
trailer for that but there's no event it
doesn't feel like anyone's coming in
coming together going to the movies is
an event
and when you have a movie whether it's a
Black Adam or a nope
that's like you just you feel it there's
a there's a build up to it you're like I
can't wait to see this I I can't wait oh
look there's a trailer coming out for
this the gray man oh okay I'll see it
when I see it
and also to the the half hour in the
theater before it starts and people are
finding their seats or nowadays we have
the science Heating and and there is
there's an anticipation
and and you also too kind of like look
around and I wonder how they're going to
react to it I wonder if they're gonna
like it you know are they gonna leave
you know yeah there's nothing like I
mean there's nothing like that being
again
something about film festivals that make
it special
just like going to a Premiere going to a
film Film Festival is a very unique
experience because you're seeing a lot
of these things for the first time
so the reaction you're getting are very
natural
and you don't know what people are going
to expect they have really no trailers
going into the movie sometimes there's
not even images there's usually just a
plot description and maybe one image and
you walk into something and it's
completely clean you have no
expectations so in that in that regard
that's part of that experience that
makes it special but when we go to a
regular movie theater right it's the
crowd around you do they laugh at
certain moments do they cry at certain
moments are they reacting
and then trailers I mean I I hate to say
this but as much as I every time I get
an email about trailer I click on it and
I look at it on my phone
trailers play differently on the big
screen so when I sit there and I'm
watching 30 minutes of trailers
I'm really starting like sometimes I
really like oh wow that looked better
now like I watched it on my computer and
I was like but now I'm watching on the
big screen that looks great and other
times I kind of go oh yeah that looks
just as crappy here but at the same time
like that's something that is part of
the experience and you get to get to see
like oh
what am I going to get hyped up for next
you lose that on streaming once the
streaming movie ends right you get a
little thing on the bottom
do you want to watch dope sick I don't
know I don't know if I'm gonna watch
dope sick right now nah sorry but yeah
that's what it is you you almost like
the theatrical experience is so special
for so many reasons because it's a
shared experience but also
there's a build up to it you literally
get to go to a movie you get to see a
bunch of trailers and kind of go oh that
looks good and then you hear someone
else go it looks like
you know and it's and it's great it's
that but it it's it it sets up the next
one I'm gonna come to the theater again
to see you know Black Adam all right
great what are you gonna see after
blackout oh look look they just showed a
don't worry darling trailer okay I'm
gonna go see that next you don't get
that you don't get that with streaming
it's it's lost it's lost and it also
the discovery of things
in Theatrical
is so much longer right it's like people
go to see movies multiple times in
theaters and they talk about it like oh
I went back to see Thor for the second
time
and I had a better experience or man
those those negatives that I had even
worse the second time around
streaming it's like people watch it once
and that's it they're done
and you're forced is this so important
so important about theatrical
is that you don't pause
you have to sit and you have to
experience it in one sitting you might
have to go to the bathroom and get up
and leave and miss something in the
movie
but you have to pay attention to it when
you're at home and again so much stuff
is out there
you're gonna pause at nine times oh the
door's ringing hey you hungry you want a
snack let's go into the kitchen get that
you really like if you want a snack and
then move there and you're really in a
really good movie there's like a pause
like I really want popcorn but this
movie's really good so I don't think I'm
gonna get up right now
so that's I think all those elements are
why theatrical is better sure I mean
they'd be a few times where you're like
you know what this is do it Blockbuster
tomorrow I'll watch it one more time
yeah I really want to get my money's
worth you know but but that was rare
yeah it was like one and done sort of
thing but I I agree yeah the street the
streaming stuff is just
there's so few things that I watched on
streaming where like I immediately have
a reaction of wanting to watch it again
it's just just very few and far between
what do you think about the gray man
having a is it a one-week theatrical run
yes okay so this is
Netflix's approach to playing nice and
nice with the theaters
um
I think
being a disrupter for so many years
has really kind of come back and bit
them in the ass
and again don't get me wrong
they've done so much in terms of content
and then TV shows
creating so many great iconic TV shows
you know their whole platform was pretty
much launched on House of Cards and
Orange is the New Black
but they really did set the bar of kind
of like we're gonna produce
our own movies we're going to produce
our own TV shows and they're going to be
on our platform and our platform only
and we own the rights to them and we
don't need theaters and we don't need
this
and they sort of had to figure out a
solution because they wanted to be part
of the awards conversation and their way
that they did it because of the Academia
rules is that they said you only have to
play in one theater in New York and L.A
and you have to play for a week
so they did the bare minimum
and when you start having movies
with these big actors whether it's red
notice whether it's the gray man
you're not going to have that same
experience
watching it and on on Netflix at home as
you are in a theater
because these movies are made like these
are these are directors and stars who
like make movies that are there for
theater
you're you have you hire the Russo
brothers and you're gonna get one week
and it's not even playing at AMC or
Regal it's only playing at Cinemark
because
they haven't negotiated their contracts
yet of getting it because they don't
know what's going to happen and also
they disrupted the industry for so long
that people are like I don't think as
willing to play with them like they
don't they want to come to the sandbox
now and be like hey can I have your
shovel and I want to dig with you and
people are a little bit more resistant
to it
and I think sadly that does a lot of
these movies a great disservice because
I think they would play better when you
when you have a movie
like the power of the dog which
for the record I didn't care that much
about
but it has an audience it was the type
of movie that you would see at your
small independent theater I always use
the the Lemley and um Encino like the
one where like I feel like the
50-somethings always go to and like they
go to on an afternoon they sit there and
you know and Jenny and Bob sit there and
I go oh what do you want to see I feel
like that movie would have played there
for like months right it just would have
been like there for months and and they
would have went to see it and they would
have told you know Rosie and Jack to see
it and everyone would have came and seen
it you don't really have that with with
Netflix movies is that they get the the
one week
they come in and again
what's the
for people who are not like me who are
obsessed with movies and like the
experience people were just watching it
it's just another movie that's what we
often forget
it's just another movie it's just enough
like as soon as you see this it's on to
the next one and the average person
doesn't care if they're watching on
their phone or that but again if you
want to create an experience
and you want more people talking about
it that's why theatrical is so important
and it's going to be I think it's going
to take a lot of a lot of time before
Netflix gets it they they're going to
try for knives out too that's that's the
one they have to push they already got
the green light to Premiere at
the Toronto International Film Festival
they're gonna have to really push that
for theatrical because the first one was
a theatrical movie and people know what
it is so they're gonna that's gonna be
their test run of how to get
people off the couch from watching
Netflix to theaters but I really do
wonder how many theaters are actually
going to play it